I have manifested thy name unto the men
which thou gavest me out of the world
thine they were and thou gavest them me
and they have kept Thy word now they
have known that all things whatsoever
thou has given me are of thee for I have
given unto them The Words which thou
gavest me and they have received them
and have known surely that and have
known surely that I came out from thee
and they have believed that thou did
send me I pray for them I pray not for
the world but I pray for them that thou
has given me
for they are Vine and all mine are Vine
and thine are mine and I am glorified in
them and now I am not in the world but
these are in the world and I come to the
Holy Father keep through thine own name
Those whom thou has given me that they
may be one even as we are
welcome to q a with Randy with elder
Randy skeet on victory over sin I am
your host Denise mccurtchen let's begin
with a word of Prayer
dear Lord we thank you for the very
breath that we breathe we thank you for
the opportunity to open the pages of
holy writ and I ask father that you will
forgive us of our sins grant us your
Holy Spirit and in a special way anoint
your man's servant Elder Randy skeet put
your words in his mouth and I pray
father that we will leave here with a
stronger determination to obey you to be
more like you and that we will surrender
our hearts our minds our entire being to
you we thank you for hearing and for
answering this prayer in the name of
Jesus Christ
our special guest today is No Stranger
In fact I consider him family he has
traveled the world the far ends of the
world spreading the gospel
that saves lives he has as well studied
for the ministry at Oakwood University
university and the Theological Seminary
at Andrews University he is a humble man
of God determined to live his being for
the master and to develop intimate
relationships with the persons that God
puts in his path so that they can be
saved and indeed he is a nice man I
speak of none other than Elder Randy
skeet
you always make me laugh when you say
that he's a nice man
well thank you for the undeserved
compliment I appreciate it very much I
say always and I'll say again I am
honored I really am to be a part of this
program I was talking to someone earlier
today about this program and how much it
means to me and why I had to make it a
part of today's activities despite the
fact I'm right now at a youth conference
and I have to speak several times and so
thank you Denisha for allowing me to be
a part of this may Lord bless you may
the Lord bless all those who are
listening and may God give me and anyone
else the right responses to the
questions that shall be put to us thank
you again
amen thank you I'll just keep the humble
privilege is ours
in our discourse on victory over sin we
will Begin by analyzing what is sin and
that's our first question what is sin
very important question there's a simple
response first John chapter 3 verse 4
whosoever committed sin transgressive
also the law for sin is the
transgression of the law now sin may
also be seen as separation from God
and separation from God is also
separation from God's law which is God's
standard of righteousness and so sin yes
is the violation of God's law sin is
also a state of sin is the natural
inability to obey God's law Romans 8
verse 7 and forsake particularly because
the carnal mind is enmity against God
for it is not subject to the law of God
neither it can be that is a state of sin
as slightly different from an act of sin
an act of sin results from a state of
sin the state makes me incapable of
obeying God incapable of pleasing God
Jeremiah chapter 13 verse 23 can the
Ethiopian change your skin or the
leopard his spots then may also do good
there are accustomed to do evil in other
words person in the carnal flesh
unrenewed unconverted cannot do good as
God defines good sin therefore is
fundamentally separation from God that's
a state the Bible also says sin is the
violation of the law of God that's the
one we know most popularly
amen thank you this key for giving us
those various perspectives that Beyond
being just an act of violating God's law
excuse me sin is can also be a state a
state of mind you know a state of nature
where we are aversed to that which is
good and are in a unable to do that
which is good in and of our own power
and strength so now that we've
understood what sin is mention something
before we get into that yes
with regard to an act of sin and the
state of sin
we need to be delivered from the
condition of being a sinner which means
I cannot please God Romans 8 verse 8.
now we are not held guilty for that
state because we inherited it are you
following me we're born with a sinful
nature we're not held guilty for that
we're held guilty for acts of sin
are you following me but we need to be
delivered from the state of sin we need
to be delivered from separation from God
we need to be delivered from that when
we're delivered from that then we can
have victory over acts of sin we are
delivered from the state of sin Isaiah
59 2 your iniquities have set and your
sins have separated between you and your
God and the function of Christ is to
bridge that Gap and restore Harmony
between God and us and so this state of
sin we're not morally responsible for
that we are morally responsible for the
choices we make contrary to God's law
but to make the right choice we have to
be delivered from the state of sin I
hope I didn't confuse anyone no no
you've made it plain it's like for
example we are inside an inside an
environment we're inside that
environment we have access to sin to do
what is against God's law but God gives
us deliverance from
we are now in the right Arena to choose
the right all right so we kind of
touched this but our second question is
is are we born with sinful inclinations
and I know absolutely yes oh yes we were
born from top to bottom with sinful
English in the sense that our natural
desire is to sin
that's where we're born because we're
born hating God and the person who hates
God loves sin we are born hating God and
loving sin
Romans 8 7 again the carnal mind is
enmity against God I've said frequently
it is not enmity against Church
attendance it's not enmity against a
vegetarian diet it is enmity against God
a person who is the personification of
righteousness and Holiness and right
doing and Purity we are enmity against
that person
and we have to be delivered from that in
order to serve him so yes we are born
with an Inuit calls it a bent towards
evil which unaided we cannot resist if
this is righteousness on this side and
this is sin we're born leaning towards
him
that's our natural condition now we
require another power to switch that
lane in the opposite direction that's
the power of Christ we are born leaning
towards sin preferring sin and hating
God and all that is of god that's the
way we're born
Lord is born with a desire for God no
one
it is God that puts it in our hearts to
desire him you cannot of the carnal
nature desire God the carnal nature does
not desire God it does not even see God
Romans 3 verse 11 this land that
understandeth there is none that seeketh
after God if we were of ourselves able
to see God there would have been no need
for Christ to say the son of man has
come to seek and to save it is he who
seeks us because we do not see him
that's just the way we're born so we're
born preferring sin we're wired to sin
until we're born again then we're wired
by constant wiring to do what is right
and I say constant wiring it requires
constant surrender
amen amen thank you for making that
plain Elder skeet
so we are swiftly moving on to our next
three questions which will be asked by
sister Alana kwashi okay
thank you my dear sister God bless you
thank you so my first question is what
does it mean to have victory over sin
and how do we achieve it okay
virtue of a sin is achieved in Christ
through the power of the word the
conference where I am now the the theme
is according to Thy word Psalm 119 verse
9. we're with all shall a young man
cleanse his way by taking his thereto
according to Thy word the victory of a
sin has to be done in Christ and by the
power of the word for instance let's go
to Psalm 119 and verse 133 just one
verse but I let someone read it Psalm
119 verse 1 3 3. it's a very very
encouraging verse
order my steps in thy word and let not
any iniquity have dominion over me
listen to the words again order my steps
who does the ordering God in other words
guide me lead me according to your word
order my steps in thy word let not any
iniquity have dominion over me and so
David prays father do not allow any sin
to dominate my life or to become an
addiction or an obsession but do that by
putting my feet in your word let me walk
according to your word now we go to
Psalm 19 verse 13. keep back thy servant
also from presumptuous sins let them not
have dominion over me when you conquer a
Dominion you have conquered sin and so
we Conquest in through a relationship
with Christ and by the power of His word
Psalm 119 verse 11 Thy word have I hid
in my heart that I might not sin against
thee John 15 verse 3 now you clean
through the word which I have spoken
unto you Jesus prayed John 17 7 17
sanctify them through thy truth Thy word
is truth the power is the word but the
word works for us when we are in Union
with Christ because he himself is the
word victory over sin is through a union
with Christ and the daily application of
the power of God's word through study
and obedience Christ's object lessons
paid 100 paragraph one if studied and
obeyed the word of God works in the
heart subduing every Unholy attribute
victory of a sin is essential for
entrance into God's kingdom Revelation 3
21 either overcometh we like Grant to
sit with me in my throne even as I also
overcame and I'm set now with my father
in his throne the only thing you and I
are to overcome is sin and it's a side
effects we must overcome these things
through a relationship with Christ
because it is the Life of Christ that is
the power that allows us to come to sin
I say again it is the Life of Christ
sometimes to all of the blood of Christ
which gives us the power and that same
life is in his word victory of a sin is
not only possible it is absolutely
required
not 50 years from now day by day we must
seek to come to sin
considering you know what we were
talking about earlier before we were
talking about Temptation and trials and
how we must go through those things
though we go through those things we
should still be thankful for our
thankfulness we should still remember
that God overcame and just as God
overcame that's right
my second question that says what about
sins we don't even realize are we
committing how do we overcome them
well their overcome first God has to
bring it to your attention that you're
doing this you see an ignorant sin is
still a sin now you're not held guilty
nor am I because we don't know but it is
still a sin and sin always causes damage
and so ignorant sin damages the person
but God in his Mercy does not hold the
personal responsible because the times
of this ignorance God winter uh acts 17
verse 30 but it is God's desire that we
know we're doing something that's not
right because an ignorant sin not only
hurts us it hurts Christ it hurts God
because Sin is Sin and so what God does
he brings our attention that we're doing
this thing and because we have a
relationship with him when it comes to
our Attention our Instinct under the
moving of the holy spirit is to say
sorry Father I was not aware I am sorry
forgive me and give me the strength to
avoid it God wants us to become aware
that there's some things we're doing
ignorantly that is why it is always good
when when you're praying to ask God
forgive me for things I may have done of
which I'm not aware
amen
my last question before
Denisha is when do we gain the victory
over sin before Christ's second Advent
or after
getting Victory I was saying after that
the Advent is not it's not biblical at
all it must be before he comes
before he comes we must Conquest him so
that he can say either this just either
just holy let him be holy still that
pronouncement has to be made in the most
holy place as Christ brings them into
his intercessory where as the high
priest as he brings to a close the
investigative judgment so that he can
say either this holy let him be holy
still it is unjust let him be unjust
still when that is made that's when we
have the victory now we won't even know
that
we'll still be praying searching
ourselves our hearts confessing whether
we're ever sin or not we confess because
we know Sinners we might have done
something but in heaven our declaration
has been made either this holy let him
be holy still it has to happen before
Christ comes but we won't know yes we
won't know we can't say oh yesterday I
conquered sin completely
every day we're wrestling striving Paul
told Timothy thank the good sight of
faith not just on Tuesday until Jesus
comes when this Mortal puts on
immortality the carnal Niche is
destroyed then there's no more sin to
fight against
no more carnal nature to push us towards
sin victory over sin must occur before
Christ comes but comes but we must look
for victories in Daily struggles daily
Temptations so you're tempted to do this
or that on a day-to-day basis you ask
God for strength and so daily conquest
of a sin leads to eventual Congress over
sin overall but of course we do not know
when that occurs all we know is every
day in the power of Christ I'm fighting
sin and temptation
but it must be something we desire we
must hate sin
and his very first promise of the Bible
Genesis 3 verse 15 I will put enmity
between thee and the woman between thy
seed and her seat God will put it in the
woman the seed of the woman Christ and
we're part of the body of Christ to hate
the things of Satan ask God to put sin
ape stream for sin in your heart he will
do that so that God can say of us as he
said of Jesus in Hebrews 1 verse 9 that
has love righteousness and hated
iniquity we were the things we hate we
avoid we must hate sin when we hate sin
we avoid it
or when we love righteousness we strive
for it and so we we're told in The
Sermon on the Mount blessed that they
wish to hang them first after
righteousness they shall be filled and
someone filled with righteousness has no
room for sin because they can't occupy
the same space
someone filled with righteousness and
you're not filled until you feel to the
brim
has no room for sin
the devil's Ploy is to get us to believe
we cannot conquer sin you see it's a
tremendous Temptation you cannot conquer
sin you may conquer some sins but the
devil's Ploy is against us to believe we
cannot conquer all sin sin is conquered
in the strength of Christ it's required
of Heaven and the possibility exists in
a relationship with Christ and the power
of the words
so we can't do it alone
absolutely we can sit alone we can't
caucus sin alone we can commit sin
without any help from God we Congress
him withheld from God yes my good sister
thank you amen Indonesia
amen amen thank you so much Elder skeet
and sister Alana for that discussion and
I think that's a perfect segue because
our next question asks what role does
Jesus play and helping us gain the
victory over sin
it is the Life of Christ in US you see
righteousness is a life
it's another word for righteousness is
the Life of Christ there is no sin in
righteousness Jesus said in John 3 Verse
6 that which is born of the flesh is
flesh that which is born of the spirit
is Spirit when you're born again you're
born of the spirit then you begin to
live you may slip and fall from time to
time a slip and fall does not make you a
practicing sinner a slip and fall means
you're growing in Grace and you have to
learn some things
The Life of Christ in us as it is more
fully expressed by constant surrender it
eventually brings us to the place where
no sin can be victorious over us so it's
the Life of Christ in Us and how is that
life brought To Us by the Spirit-filled
word of God let me say it again by the
Spirit-filled word of God that's how the
lives of Christ is and he tells us in
John chapter 6 Eat My Flesh and drink my
blood what he meant was his word he
clarifies that in verse 63 it is the
spirit the quickness the flesh Prophet
is nothing the words that I speak unto
you they are spirit and their life it is
the word of God obeyed believe that
brings to us The Life of Christ and I
mean the Life of Christ we may not be
able to understand understand all the
details of how it works but we believe
based on God's word we receive the Life
of Christ we really do
because that's the only Power that can
come to sin
that's the same way it was the Life of
Christ only that could pay for sin only
that life can conquer sin but we must
cooperate with God by constant surrender
alloy tells us in Desire of Ages page
324 paragraph one thus by constant
surrender to God
we may have been able to live the new
life the life of faith I know that's um
steps to Christ page 47 48 paragraphs
one and two uh these are 324 paragraph
one by a constant communion continual
communion and a personal acquaintance
that's the secret of being Victorious
over sin a constant
communion
and a personal acquaintance with Jesus
Christ
sin is not easily conquered but it's
concrete
it is concrete and the life of Xeno is
an example for us the ultimate example
is Christ but at a lower level of the
life of Enoch is an example for us he
just he conquered Sinners Like by the
power of Christ and Christ just took him
up we no longer belong on this Earth
come
into an atmosphere where there's no sin
come up and God wants to say all of us
finally come up to the same atmosphere
where there is no sin
The Life of Christ in a person is the
power to conquer sin and that light is
in his words
the spirit
sorry powerful powerful you know because
oftentimes we say oh I can't overcome
this habit or I can't change this this
is just what I've been doing you know
for all my life and my father my
grandfather has been doing this and so
forth but when we undermine our ability
to overcome you're actually spiting the
Life of Christ it's like saying Jesus
you're not enough you're not able to
help me overcome
but when his life is in ours our life is
hid with Christ and God that's right the
key is
surrendering constant surrender to Jesus
you can have the victory over sin that's
right no God God asks Abraham a question
in Genesis 18 14 when he appeared to him
with two angels
he said is there anything too hard for
the Lord and the person who says I
cannot conquer this or that must answer
that question is anything too hard for
the Lord when the angel Gabriel prayed
to Mary Luke chapter 1 told her she'd
have a child that wasn't a possibility
because she said I know not a man he
explained how the impossible would be
made possible the Holy Ghost will come
upon you and what is physiologically
possible will happen then he told in
verse 36 your cousin Elizabeth have also
conceived a son in her old age who was
called Barren she was barren
unless you have a son verse 37 for with
God nothing shall be impossible it is a
disrespectful act against God to say I
cannot conquer this sin or that sin by
yourselves by myself absolutely not in
Union with Christ
we can buy the power of Christ you and I
do not have power to come to sin we may
resist this act or that act but we
cannot resist the principle of sin the
power of sin the natural tendency to sin
we cannot conquer that only Christ can
by the way behavior modification is not
victory over sin
there are some people who decide to
drink no more smoke no more take drugs
no more that is behavior modification
to say I no longer submit to the power
of sin only Christ you can do that in
you with your cooperation so the victory
of the sin is more than behavior
modification it's a change of nature
so one nature dominates the Earth prior
to Christ is a carnal nature now you
surrender the price it is his nature
working in you the same way God put his
life on his character in dirt he can put
his life in US
and that's what he wants to do there's
no other way but the Life of Christ
through the spiritual word and I keep
saying Spirit Phil because the Holy
Ghost must be part of this
and he breathed the word to the Bible
righteous This Life of Christ in the
Spirit-filled word constantly applied by
studying and surrender
and obedience
you do not come to sin by osmosis
amen you know this goes back to the
first question and your response in
terms of defining sin as a state and
also an act you know we may be able to
change our actions here yes but that
state you cannot no you can't we can't
you can't
and that state cannot be changed what
changes is its dominance in your life
that changes that state will be
destroyed when price comes when this
Mortal puts on immortality but until
then every converted person has the
correlation its dominance is broken and
the spirit of God the spiritual nature
now sits on the throne of your life
so that correlation does not die it
remains but it is overpowered by the
spirit of Christ by the spiritual nature
that's what happens when Christ comes
the correlation is finally destroyed but
until then you still have it
but it is now no longer the boss of your
life
spirit of God the spirit of Christ is
now the director of your life that's the
difference
and so you can say no to the carnal
nature Paul tells us in Galatians 5 17
the flesh lusteth against the spirit and
the spirit against the Flesh and these
that contrary one to another that battle
goes on and on every day it goes on
but we enjoy victory victory victory in
Christ and the more we enjoy Victory the
more we want victory
and the weekend at carnal nature becomes
it can be weakened by constant
bombardment from the spiritual uh Armory
the spiritual weapons constant
bombardment weakens the carnal laser but
doesn't die until Christ comes
and this Mortal puts on immortality amen
amen amen you know all this key as you
were speaking I'm thinking
thinking have for example
you know some
quitting one day I mean sometimes God
does something supernaturally yes you
know no longer have the craving but
oftentimes you know they go through
withdrawal you know sometimes their body
shakes sometimes their headaches start
and you know it's like I want to go back
to this but as you said we have to
constantly suppress constantly say no
constantly I'm not going to pick up that
cigarette or maybe for us it may not be
a cigarette it may be a bad habit and
then we can literally we did
in the Bible we can literally use verses
in the Bible to help us overcome sin one
of them you you mentioned before Psalm
119 133
constant surrender to Jesus Christ now
let me say this
the person may want to conquer drugs
because drugs causes drugs cause a
problem for that person
that's a lot of motivations for creating
drugs the motivation must be so I can
have a relationship with God
without the interference of this demonic
substance the motivation is very very
important and it affects the victory if
your motivation is looked I need to stop
drinking it's affecting my wallet
negatively then you that's not the right
motivation it's a good motivation don't
misunderstand me but the motivation must
always be the glory of God I want to
stop drugs because it does not glorify
God I want to be in a position where I
can represent God more fully I can enjoy
your relationship with my savior my
Creator and drugs that interfere with
that alcohol is interfering with that
gambling interferes with that I want to
conquer that thing that's interfering
with my relationship with God not
because it's
causing me to go broke or it causes my
girlfriend to leave me those are good
reasons yes but the driving motivation
must be I want to stop drinking because
it displeases God
I want to stop running around it
displeases God so God is the Reason God
and for Jesus Christ John 8 29 and he
that have sent me is with me the father
hath not left me alone for I do always
those things that please him this was
the motivation of Jesus Christ father if
thou be willing remove this cup from me
nevertheless not my will but thy I must
want to conquer drugs because drugs
interfere with my relationship with God
God must be the motivation not economics
mm-hmm
you see
many times people do not completely
surrender to God
we'd be shocked the amount of Miracles
God would perform if we gave him total
surrender
total surrender
we may see miracles in our lives and
other people's lives surrender without
one microscopic reservation
hello I said if we do that
the mighty Works God did in Christ he'll
do in US
the question a person may have to ask am
I totally surrendered to God my will
that capacity to choose have I given
that to God
and that could be the reason why
sometimes some of us struggle and
struggling struggle our surrender is not
complete and it's not constant
if it's complete on Tuesday we must
renew that on Wednesday or renew several
times on Tuesday it doesn't take that
long
to say father I
recommit my will to you
nine o'clock in the morning dude at 10
noon 11. five second statement
constant surrender
everybody says Moment by moment this is
paid 324 paragraph one
constant surrender steps to Christ page
48 paragraph one constant surrender
people think what I got baptized in
April then I don't need to surrender
anymore wrong wrong get baptized every
day in your mind
all right um
saying too much let's take the next
question no amen amen Elder skeet our
next question in our final official
question is what is the relationship
between forgiveness and victory over sin
oh well go to Matthew chapter 6.
Matthew 6.
read let's read from nigh we read The
Lord's Prayer then we go all the way to
15.
all right
after this manner therefore ye Our
Father which art in heaven Hallowed be
thy name thy kingdom come thy will be
done on Earth as it is in heaven give us
this day our daily bread and forgive us
our debts as we forgive our debtors and
lead us not into temptation but Deliver
Us from Evil for thine is the kingdom
the power and the glory
but if ye forgive not mend their
trespasses neither will your father
forgive yourself
an unforgiving sin is not a conquered
sin
are you with me I'm unforgiving sin is
not a conquered sin
forgiving others is associated with
conquering sin because a refusal to
forgive is itself a sin but you need to
conquer did I say that clearly
the refusal to forgive is itself a sin
and the only way to conquer that sin is
to forgive people and so a refusal to be
forgive people interferes with my desire
to Conquest in because what I'm doing is
practicing sin by not forgiving someone
and I'm literally putting my eternal
salvation at risk because if God doesn't
forgive me I cannot be saved
read verse 15.
but if he
Matthew 6 15. yes all right I clicked
the wrong button and got okay on a whole
different screen but if he forgive not
men the trespasses neither will your
father forgive your trespasses so if you
forgive Lord forgives you you don't
forgive God does not forgive you
forgiving others is associated with
victory of a sin because not forgiving
is itself a sin and there are some
people members of the church they have
been investing for decades there's
someone that Refuge to forgive
because the person hurt them so badly
but there's no hurt like Calvary I mean
like sin
that's worth Christ and he forgives us
how does it may be for us it's possible
for God
and God working in us will lead us to
forgive people
if I will not forgive I cannot conquer
sin you see conquest of sin means
conquest of all sin that's known all
nonsense conquest of a sin
you can't say I've concrete 99 but I'm
holding on to a refusal to forgive
people that doesn't work Adam was put
out of the garden for one sin you and I
can be victim from heaven for one or
prevented from entering heaven for one
you must forgive people
even if you cry as you do it you must do
it
if you don't you're sinning
and that person may enter Heaven while
you go to hell
it's a serious thing people do not
forgive people
and they serve a God who forgives
anything that's confessed
next question
all right I'll Escape thank you so much
we have come to the end of our official
q a segment and we're we're taking some
open Forum questions on the subject of
sins yes so Alana had submitted some and
Sean Williams submitted some as well uh
end time launcher I see your question in
the chat and brother Arnold I see your
question as well I am so sorry because
they're not on the topic we will not be
able to let's pick the ones on the top
of them so if you have any questions on
the on the topic at hand feel free to
use the raise your hand feature I'll
mute you and you can ask your question
on the topic of victory over sin
all right so sister lion will take one
of your questions
okay since this one is on the topic of
forgiveness okay so she asks how do I
know I have forgiven someone sometimes
by forgiving the person oh simple
I should give you that's it
in the name of Jesus Christ I should
give you mm-hmm
and pray for that person
you don't have to feel
like forgiving you've been told to
forgive the Bible says don't kill you
don't have to feel like not killing to
not kill are you following me we depend
too much on feeling obedience to God has
nothing to do with feeling what does the
law say God says forgive
you go to that person say you've hurt me
here's what you did here are the effects
on my life here are the consequences
I've suffered but I forgive you and by
saying it what you never felt before you
may feel you say it in the name of Jesus
Christ I forgive you don't wait to feel
even if it hurts you as you say you may
cry say it
because God tells you to say it
and pray for that person
amen there's power in our words there
are there's power in Words If any man if
we will confess to our mouths the Lord
Jesus you see him believe in your heart
if something has to come out of this
Peter said Lord save me the blind man
said have mercy upon me you know he said
they said something to Jesus and he
responded
amen amen
well Sean I see that a lot of the
questions you asked we covered this one
oh this kid I'll pose it and then well
you can see the question is if Grace is
imparted by God's love this victory over
sin the same
is all of Grace and love it's all of
Grace
without God you and I cannot conquer sin
without the grace of God we cannot even
feel convicted of sin without the grace
of God we cannot confess because all
these things do not proceed from the
flesh the flesh does not confess the
flesh does not feel sorry the flesh does
not hate sin these are impulses God puts
in us because of his grace
and the spirit urges us now to act on
those impulses
steps of Christ speech 26 paragraph
three Christ is the source of every
right impulse and a desire to forgive I
desire to confess is or our right
impulses they come from Christ without
the grace of God
no one can come to sin
the greatest act of God's grace of
course is Calvary
amen amen thank you all the skeet well
end time Watcher I see that your hand is
raised so you can unmute now and pose
your question
hello
these kids how do you do my good brother
God bless you from the Caribbean
Trinidad oh good place remember Tobago
not just Trinidad Trinidad and Tobago
um no my question is just a little it's
not
um as do we need seven last week right
um well and then um this kind of uh
claim yeah well
um Ellen White will she who threw this
seven last thing or will she resurrect
at the seventh League over two years
they were very special uh Resurrection
or at the seventh grade
that has nothing to do with sin
um
but no dead person will go to the seven
aspect God doesn't raise anyone else to
go to the seven last plagues no
mm-hmm
so she will
be those who died
to see Christ come that's after the
plagues have fallen
the world is still in turmoil don't
misunderstand me won't be peaceful it'll
be a turmoil but after the seven plagues
have fallen
is to punish the sinful world not to
raise up Saints to punish them are you
following me
yeah the purpose of the seven last play
through Revelation 14. those are the
mark of the beast they suffer the seven
last plays so God can't raise up his
righteous dead to suffer the Civil
aspect when that's done he raised not to
see Christ come
alive the third Angels message
nice yeah absolutely nice
Western
God bless you
all right so I okay so friends please
let us keep our questions tailored to
the topic
um we spoke a little bit on forgiveness
and brother Lorenzo meon has acts on
YouTube do you forgive someone who has
not said sorry for what I did yes
Christ provided his blood while we were
Sinners Romans 5 6 Romans 5 8 Romans 5
10 why we were weak he died for the
guardian while we were Sinners he died
while there were enemies he died he
didn't wait for us to say sorry we could
not say sorry
because we're in sin his death his
sacrifice provided a means for us to say
sorry without the death of Christ his
sacrifice his atonement no one could say
sorry so you don't forgive someone who
says sorry you forgive someone who has
done you wrong whether the person admits
it or not the the the the command to
forgive is not based on how someone else
behaves is based on you
you forgive
whether the person accepts you or
forgiveness or not you say I forgive you
do you do it sincerely leave the rest of
God don't wait for some of your story
that almost sounds uh
like a tinge of parasitical arrogance no
no someone has wronged you say look
you've done me wrong I forgive you
because I'm Duty Bound by God to forgive
you regardless of how you behave I must
forgive you and I forgive you God bless
you
you know living your heavenly lifestyle
is tough when you think of it from an
Earthly mind because the lifestyle of
Heaven is absolutely opposite of the
lifestyle of Earth
there's two different systems Heaven's
system is forgiveness
Earth system is come crawling to me and
apologize and I'll forgive
that's the way God functions we must
function like Christ he died for people
who hated him
amen amen I just want to read what a
virtuous woman put in the chat on
YouTube she said refuse to hold a grudge
no quest for retaliation even
remembering that you have been wrong
someone let God help you put another
coat of forgiveness over it thank him
for forgiveness move on amen amen is
your son than done but as Elvis you said
is there anything to we've got all
things are possible yes it is so we have
two hands raised here
um in Zoom I'll take brother Arnold feel
free to it maybe it may it may be better
to give me written questions we don't
know what the reason will ask I know I
will try to be hard but I don't want to
go off the substance a raised hand does
not tell you what the question is that's
true that's true a written question we
can make a judgment of
God bless the rest of misunderstanding
yes yes all right so brother Arnold
please if you would
just abide by our little request to keep
your question to the topic we would
greatly appreciate it so let me
a light too
are we guilty of Adam's sin it's not a
question people ask
yeah we're not guilty about him
we inherit essential names from Adam
we're not guilty of Adam's sin but we
inherited a nature that gives us a
preference for sin and we need to be
delivered from that but we're not held
responsible for Adam's sin
because we didn't commit
individually by individual choice we did
but we have been affected by it and we
need to be delivered from that effect
which is a carnal Nation that prefers
sin and hates God
peace Elder skeet
yes
how are you
I'm fine oh I just enjoy very much of
your episodes on YouTube
[Music]
yeah
oh good good good look yeah
I have a friend who challenged me you
know uh they organize our Sabbath papers
that I don't attend I have to go to
church good
yes and I he challenged me using Matthew
chapter 12 from verse 1 to 8.
and I was really shy I had to run away
okay
get my email I'll have the Misha tell
send my email to you write me
okay yeah let the Nisha send you my
email write me and we'll we'll discuss
that
okay Elda and another thing uh
it this
is this thing and we want to host you
here in masaka okay all right
I was there in 2001 had a beautiful time
okay pretty hard ask God for directions
okay all right thank you very much I
enjoy your episodes
I mean
amen amen all right that was nice other
skeet yeah actual tongues yeah I love
you again I love Uganda I miss Uganda
actually very much
wow I do I have some of my loveliest
experiences in Uganda
the pearl of Africa
all right so Prince Eli you can now ask
your question attuned to our topic on
victory over sin over sin
yeah good evening from this trains from
Ghana Ghana is a good place I've been
there about seven times
please can you hear me
I can hear you you're from Ghana God
bless Ghana
um
yeah I would ask if you venture on
Satan's ground do you have any Assurance
from Christ to be saved from that sin
say that again
if you venture on Satan's gown yes do
you have any Assurance to be safe not
while you're on settings
no no
go to Hebrews chapter 10 if you have
your Bible
you have a Bible with you
go to Hebrews 10 reasons
Hebrews 10 26.
that's a very important question to us
thanks for it
26 says for if we sin willfully
after that received the knowledge of the
truth knowledge
keep read verse 27.
but a certain fearful
accepting fearful looking for looking
for of judgment and sharing indignation
that's right if we deliberately go on
Satan's ground while we're on Satan's
ground there is no guarantee of victory
for Christ we went looking for the devil
and you'll find him
that's why the psalmist prayed in Psalm
1 Psalm 19 Verse 30 and keep back that
servant thy servant also from
presumptuous sins
don't go on Satan's grounded and say
Lord I need victory
when God described job as a perfect man
he said he fears he has choose evil he
avoids one of the techniques the
Congress in is avoid now if you go to
Santa's ground you realize look I
shouldn't have done this you're
genuinely sorry Father I'm sorry that's
a different story yes the Lord will
intervene
but you can't be arrogant
during what's wrong deliberately and
then saying father save me in my sin
that doesn't work Christ came to save us
from our sin not to save us while we're
on Satan's ground if that were the case
God would have saved the Israelites in
Egypt but he got them out of Egypt which
was Satan's ground
God bless you God bless God
I think I think his connection maybe oh
yeah I know okay I'm sorry so I think
what we have over common sense
are you okay now
go ahead I'm listening
okay daily hourly Moment by moment so it
means that
overcoming a particular season in the
life
you have to be conscious over it
and work towards it do you have to work
towards it yes you have to work towards
it you have a role to play that's why
Paul told Timothy in first Timothy 6 12
fight the good fight of faith James the
half-brother of Christ tells us in James
4 7 submit yourself there for the god
resist the devil Peter tells us how whom
resists steadfast in the faith first
Peter 5 uh verse 8 and 9. so we have to
resist this enemy that's walking about
like a roaring lion seeking whom he made
a flower it's an active thing the Bible
tells us behold I come quickly hold that
fast which thou has that romantic thy
crime Revelation 3 11. so there's an
active role you play but the power that
makes your effort effective is the Life
of Christ
which is in his word study done obeyed
constant surrender leaning on the word
of God it's a daily battle with sin
every Victory you win it becomes easier
to win the next victory
and every loss makes next loss easier
but we want Victory we want victories
so they become a habit in the life
thanks for the very important question
my brother Ghana God bless you
it's nine minutes to three
I have to go set up for my presentation
at three o'clock yes yes I have to run
away Dr Denisha sorry no no need to
apologize okay okay thank you thank you
so much Elder skeet for being with us
for our lives to be here
and to have this discussion on victory
over sin we're just praying God's
blessings on your life restore your
strength your voice as you go into that
next presentation thank you so much and
please give sister skeet our love and I
will do that and God bless you God bless
all those who tuned in from whatever
country may God bless your country may
God bless your life may God provide your
needs spiritual first then material
because we are material people may God
put a double blessing on your children
and in all that you do let nothing
interfere with your relationship with
Christ nothing and no one when I say no
one I mean no one allow no one to
interfere with your relationship with
Jesus Christ because it is first first
notice God bless you and may the Lord
save all of you when he comes without
losing one
my good sister Denisha God bless you
I'll see you again the Lord willing
yes Elder ski thank you so much God
bless you thank you bye
all right everyone so we see from our
discussion today there is a motif of
surrender
total and complete and constant
surrender to Jesus Christ with that
being said we'll close out with a song
of meditation and then brother Akeem
Charles will do our closing prayer
[Music]
foreign
freezes
[Music]
now
foreign
[Music]
pictures
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I
know
[Music]
I release
each other
[Music]
thank you
God
[Music]
to you my
dreams
[Music]
words
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
amen amen may we stay ever near The
Cross I express many thanks once again
to Elder skeet for his time thank you
sister Alana kwashi for asking those
questions and even sharing some open
Forum questions and thank you I know
Sister Renee you were unable to join
because of health reasons but thank you
for your intention and I want to
especially Express gratitude to my mom
and all of you that have joined on Zoom
those of you watching on healing of the
Nations platform those of you on YouTube
Twitter and twitch from all countries
from countries all around the world
thank you for spending this hour with us
and I pray that you are encouraged and
also admonish all of us to surrender
completely to God and it is well to
forgive that we may be forgiven we look
forward to seeing you we may have a Q
may I believe the fourth Sabbath of June
with not Elder but Pastor Dwayne Turner
so stay tuned for that we also have
Victory lake so I have to which is a
camp meeting here in the northeastern
conference so we'll see how that works
out
but thank you all for your support and
may we through the power of Jesus Christ
have victory over sin I also Express
thanks in advance to brother Akeem
Charles who will be doing our closing
prayer
good afternoon everyone
happy Sabbath
um um but Hakeem Charles how we do the
uh the closing pairs
every father I thank you Lord for waking
up uh and we you know you know in our
right mind and protecting me and I saw
this program that put together with uh
sister Denisha and
Elder
skeet
and everybody has that watching
I hope everybody that uh that watch
learn something
study it
and revise on it
and the videos saying our forgiveness
guilt and everything else
in Jesus name amen
all right
thank you so much brother Charles for
that prayer and I hope that all of you
have a wonderful rest of the Sabbath day
may we be faithful to our Lord and
savior and let's gain the victory over
sin until next time take care and God
bless
thank you
amen all right there we go let me allow
good afternoon sister candacey how are
you
well you can't unmute I have to change
the security
I don't know
hi good afternoon good morning thank you
okay awesome so you can yes yes thank
you for joining all the way from Guyana
yes great being here amen thank you
thank you
oh okay it's 10 p.m and Uganda wow thank
you for joining Arnold did you get the
the messages I sent I had sent you the
email address already and I texted you
my personal number because you wanted to
communicate on WhatsApp
and did you get those messages